okay she cheats here we go so first off
we want to thank the Academy can't
believe I'm saying that for this amazing
honor this has been such a surreal
experience none of us ever expected that
this would hit that this would ever be
possible but I guess just like animation
anything is possible having experienced
this week with our fellow filmmakers has
been unbelievable we are in total awe of
all of your vision talent and
professionalism we're also accepting
this award on behalf of our team which
included two of our other co-directors
Marie reveled and thaddeus andreas I'm
not sure that we will ever be able to
put into words to describe a kind of
chemistry that we all had as a team but
I know that we all cherish each other
and respect each other so much as
artists thank you for making this
experience on no ward in its own we also
want to take the time to thank the
computer art department staff and our
chair John Macintosh who's actually here
with us tonight fellow students at SVA
and the alumni a special thanks to
Brendan Gallagher who took the time in
this enormous world of 3d animation to
teach us the importance of falling down
and trusting our peers to pull each
other back up and also special thanks to
our professor Joe Burrus Cano who's dr
attitude and unique sense of style
really inspired us to push the
boundaries of our imaginations that you
sorry it's you oh I'm sorry we work so
well as a team yes we're great aren't we
I want to especially thank my parents
for giving me the opportunity to pursue
the American dream and for putting up
with all my pencils pens and
paintbrushes that took over every drawer
and every floor of our house also to my
brothers thank you so much for teaching
me to shamelessly jump in alongside the
boys and thank you for giving me the
Tuscan to fight for my voice and the
heart to be open to others especially
and other thanks to my team for trusting
and me to deliver a certain quality that
I wasn't sure that I believed I was
capable of and Eric thank you for not
only being our complete technical
support our pipeline guru and the doctor
but my emotional support you taught me
so much of what I know now and continue
to actually be one of my biggest
inspirations with which i think is the
greatest gift okay we those are I want
to also just thank you all for
supporting animation in general as a
medium and to those who continue to tell
thank you so much
and to those who continue continue to
tell their stories just for the pure
love of the craft thank you and I want
to thank my family and friends for being
my constant support system and always
believing in me without all of them I
would not be standing up here today I
love you all thank you to my brother
Lucas and all of my grandparents and
thank you to my parents for introducing
me to every Disney film they could when
I was a child clearly it had an effect
and all I can hope is that one day I can
give some but someone else the emotional
experience that I got out of watching
animated films and inspire them to
follow their dreams and a special thanks
to my mother who has always told me to
follow my dreams and has always been my
rock and my biggest fan I want to
dedicate this to my grandpa Jodie ganj
who was the best storyteller I ever knew